Brasil presentó esta iniciativa y
aseguró que la disputa es un tema de
interés hemisférico permanente Por qué Y
más allá de eso en la práctica la
resolución para usted tiene una
relevancia que pase de lo simbólico
bueno empiezo por el final la resolución
tiene una relevancia que
lamentablemente mientras el Reino Unido
permanezca intransigente origen a lo
simbólico lo cual no quita que la
presencia británica en el archipiélago
de las malvinas sea una amenaza regional
y por eso el recurrente apoyo de la oea
en un contexto de un mundo multipolar la
malvinas siguen siendo un puente para
amenazar o para ejercer control sobre el
continente sudamericano y también por su
proyección antártica con lo cual Es
lógico que los Estados Americanos se
expresen su preocupación y pidan una
resolución ahora mientras no se muevan
los términos de la discusión si no sale
de los simbólico claro y mientras tanto
Reino Unido pidió a la oea que se
respetara el derecho de los habitantes
de las malvinas a la autodeterminación
por qué esto una vez más No es aceptable
para los países latinoamericanos y
recordemos a nuestros televidentes
porque es tan estratégica o tan
importante la ubicación de las malvinas
bueno argentina se opone al principio
autodeterminación y en mal las Naciones
Unidas han reconocido que hay dos partes
en puna que son Gran Bretaña y la
República Argentina este porque parte de
la idea de que la población en malvinas
es una población implantada a partir de
la ocupación británica en el siglo 19
Por supuesto que si prestar atención a
la autodeterminación no habría discusión
los isleños mayoritariamente
prefieren permanecer bajo la órbita de
los británicos
Entonces los británicos lo que han hecho
después la guerra del 82 es correr
digamos la cancha de la discusión por el
territorio a la discusión por la
autodeterminación de los isleños para
evitar la cuestión principal que es
señalamiento de que es un enclave
colonial que tiene una importancia
estratégica nuevamente por su proyección
continental pero también por su
protección hacia la antártida una región
rica en minerales y agua potable no O
potencialmente potable para ser más
preciso